um thank you again for inviting me to
share a little bit about
what we're going to be
uh kind of doing to support the biomed
research and lbrn research project so
i want to briefly talk
today what i've been asked to talk about
today is primarily about
the way that we can support different
kinds of research projects that are
being run through the biomed sequencing
core and
what types of
uh questions and answers are are
possible through that and also how can
you
kind of leverage different resources
that are
kind of built into that cost structure
that is available through biomed
so
first of all i think what we discovered
is that a lot of people that potentially
could be doing
the sequencing
struggle not only with the standard
processing tools but also then having
someone to talk to and really going
deeper into their data and so we've
developed this process of first
gathering the requirements and then
providing some standard processing
outputs that are very predictable in
terms of what it is and and how much it
costs and how long it takes and then
being able to work with the researchers
to answer their custom research
questions and also provide them with the
support that they need to insert any
kind of figures in their publications or
anything like that
so i don't know exactly what is the
right link
for gene lab
but maybe ramesh or someone can post
that because i think that's where you
would be able to get all of the
sequencing
capabilities and and i think what we
provide on the analysis side is really
tied into whatever sequencing
they offer there gene lab services are
available through ilab you need to get a
ilab account and then in there you will
have we have
the services listed but we can talk
about that after your presentation
okay
and so to showcase how this works in
practice i'll talk about three
projects i'm not going to go into the
details i think most of the projects are
maybe at different stages of being
published so i'm not going to go into
what the biological question was or what
the design was i'll just show kind of
some of these stages that i'm discussing
here and what are the outcomes what do
you get at the end
so um i think one of the most
common projects rna sequencing
you know typically one of the
limitations of an rna-seq process a
project is that you get your standard
outputs you have tables but then a lot
of questions only start appearing after
you have that initial processing done
and so our goal was to really develop a
standardized pipeline from that pipeline
provide all of the different outputs
that could be potentially interesting
from gene to isoform expression uh to
annotation and kind of then be able to
work with the researcher to understand
what are the specific uh questions and
provide them support from
statistical analysis and kind of
exploratory analysis all the way down to
pathway annotation and and supporting
their specific research questions
and so here you can see right away that
you know the time that it typically
takes us so the sequencing core would
sequence uh the samples and then that
would be uploaded to the illumina bass
bass account and from there we take that
and very quickly we can produce the
initial
tables for you to kind of work with if
you know what you're doing or if you
have some additional requirements like
differential gene expression downstream
annotation then that can take a little
bit longer because typically then you
would want to focus on some specific
element and get it down to a very
detailed view of the biological
questions that you were trying to
address
another example project that i have here
is
something that is a little bit more
custom and not as widely used i would
say
so tcr sequencing
these are t cell receptors cdr3
receptors where
not only is there
a limitation i think in what the
standard output is which really just is
a proportion and quantification of
clonotypes but also a lot of
kind of results that are difficult to
deal with for example in this project
the end result was
a combination of
kind of novel sequences that no one
really
knew what to do with and so all of a
sudden a lot of questions appeared what
do you do with all of these sequences
which ones are the more important and
significant for the treatment that was
being studied and then also how can we
uh kind of create some kind of a
large-scale uh process so that we don't
have to deal with this in a manual way
going through blast and kind of
annotating results manually
so what we were able to do here is to
use statistical analysis to identify
clusters of clonal types that were
really
more abundant
in the
specific types of treatments that were
being researched here
and then
use some standard tools to predict
epitopes with good binding
properties and then use a distance
matrix or a dissimilarity matrix between
the sequences of these predicted
epitopes to then start asking questions
about what are some of the expected and
unexpected epitopes that we're finding
to really try to annotate also a lot of
the unknown sequences that were
identified
and so this project took a longer time
but i think it's a good example when you
know someone has uh maybe some specific
questions in mind and and it's typically
a bioinformatics
you know kind of a challenge to get
stuck at a certain stage and then try to
identify some yeah i think creative ways
to get out of that um situation
finally another example is an example
with single cell sequencing where uh i
think 10x genomics is a new uh sequence
a new capability that
the center has now
and
we were dealing with a project where
different time points for different cell
types where really
you know a lot of
information
is
there but we were tasked with
just kind of annotating the different
types of cells and then using a standard
procedure more or less today but
to really study how the cells
differentiate over time or the pseudo
time trajectory so we were able to not
only
i think
kind of work through the process of
eliminating some of the noisy data that
came with the project but also perform
all these tasks in a very short period
of time and then start
kind of asking those specific questions
about you know what are the marker genes
and how do these marker genes behave
across time and between different
cell populations
so those are some of the examples but i
want to summarize this part of the
presentation
to really talk about some of the reasons
why this makes sense so first of all we
work closely with the team at the biomed
lab to really understand
you know all of the information about
the samples that they have about the
preparation about the protocols that
they use and that allows us to fine-tune
our standard processing to the way that
they process those samples on their end
i think we've also established a fairly
efficient process of passing information
and the data between uh the kind of
biological research side and the
bioinformatics side
to be able to
support the researchers that have
questions that kind of span that whole
process you know they
can send out the samples or maybe they
have questions about experimental design
and so i think that is really
a major part of making the
bioinformatics process effective
another one is standard and predictable
pricing so i think it's very important
for researchers to be able to include
that pricing in their proposals uh to
plan their experiments also for lbrm to
be able to support their those projects
and so i think there we have a lot of
flexibility with
how little or how much we're able to
take on
at a specific project
and another important part of this i
think is that we have a close
collaboration with the talbot
bioinformatics research center
the center develops novel algorithms and
is working
with a lot of collaborations where new
algorithms are being developed to
address challenges
that you know don't have really
effective solutions or really need
something new to be developed and so the
benefit of that is not only that they
develop these algorithms but we're able
to
package those and make them a part of a
standardized environment where it's very
easy and
you know possible to use them in a
user-friendly way
and so to transition to that i want to
briefly mention
uh we have
a platform that is actually designed for
that use case
so as a support service oftentimes these
kinds of analyses can be time consuming
and they can be
very difficult to predict you can have
new questions appear as a result of
different stages of the analysis and
oftentimes it's not economical to try
and have somebody service every step of
the way
so the platform allows a biologist to be
much more independent with these complex
tasks
mostly for processing standard
getting standard outputs but i will show
you today a few examples of how you can
also go into the exploratory stages and
also in downstream annotation
so
as i mentioned a single cell
has been in emerging technology a lot of
people are starting to use it more and
more and so we developed a dedicated
section that now allows you to try out
different
pre-processing methods different batch
correction methods uh try out different
types of visual outputs and all of that
in a point-and-click interface that
really makes it easy to get all of the
standard outputs that you might expect
in a single cell study
not only that we also provide training
modules if you have some data set that
you would like to continuously work on
and you have a student a graduate
student that would like to kind of get
involved into that project we provide
the full support from the kind of
standardized package pipeline
to collab notebooks that you can go
through and kind of modify parameters
yourself and also develop that into a
reproducible workflow that later on you
can
use on your own
in addition to that
with a lot of sequencing being done for
source code 2 we developed a number of
tools and training resources that you
can use
to
plan those kinds of experiments and one
of these
i think focuses not only on kind of
standard consensus annotation but also
the ability to
develop these intermediate files where
you can start looking at sub-consensus
analysis
we also worked with the lbr ran
core to help
annotate and process a lot of the
samples where the major question was
annotation of uh variance of concern and
there we developed kind of a full uh
pipeline that automates uh identifying
specific positions annotating them based
on the known
kind of variance and their
classification but also being able to
generate intermediate reports to ask
deeper questions
one of those types of questions is
really around how does the sequence
affect the structure and so uh we kind
of put together that first initial stage
of
uh identifying the variance and then
also producing uh variant mapping onto
the structure of let's say the spike
protein or known structures to help uh
kind of investigate and study some of
those questions at a deeper level
and finally uh because i took over after
chris uh he's really an expert in
metagenomics and does a lot of that
kind of work uh you know we try to
simplify and make a user-friendly
version of uh
working with metagenomic data and these
are just two pipelines that we have data
to and kind to where you can not only
process the data and learn about those
kinds of analysis methods but also at
the end get some interactive
visualizations that you can customize
and on your own in incorporate into your
research so these are just some tools
that i think
supplement what we do on the server side
after the sequencing is done
from initially setting that expectation
to managing the process all the way to
supporting the publication stage and
also giving tools and support services
to continue and study that data because
as data accumulates new questions really
appear
and so far we've been able to work with
a number of institutions in the state to
support their research projects
and so if you have any questions about
that or the standard pricing ramesh will
be able to share that information with
you after that
now briefly i also want to mention
another part of what we do and i think
chris already alluded to that
a major challenge is not only in having
the knowledge of bioinformatics and even
having practical tools but also
following a proven process of learning
that allows students from different
backgrounds to acquire skills and become
independent in their approach to
biological questions using data and so
we've developed
our omics logic training around that
challenge to really support going from
the basics of terminology and
understanding to an understanding of how
experts use some of these tools in their
research projects and then becoming
independent and being able to apply
those to research questions of their own
and just this january we launched a
pilot
with the national association of idea
principal investigators
where students from several different
programs from around the country
participated in a
discussion and also a pilot program to
make these courses available throughout
the network so kind of from louisiana
exported to a lot of these new places
and so we're excited to say that we had
over 100 participants both faculty
undergraduate and graduate students
they were really successful at
going through the process and so for you
to appreciate what that process looks
like i have just a couple more slides to
explain what is it that we offer and how
is it different from the traditional
workshop approach or maybe coursework in
traditional
programs
so first of all we have a process that
allows both coding and non-coding paths
to learning and mastering bioinformatics
and what that means is that you can
appreciate bioinformatics but maybe not
have enough time to master all of the
different requirements for the technical
uh kind of you know
all the way to statistical and machine
learning and so there's really a lot to
learn so our focus is to making it
available and lowering the barrier of
entry and we do that by packaging these
complex technical things into short
coursework that is available online
and can be taken asynchronously and so
from this pilot program
we were surprised to see that a lot of
the participants
a lot of them were from hawaii
from unmc in nebraska from other places
were able to go through that whole
process and we had these five options
that people could choose from
introduction to bioinformatics which is
a very basic program introductory
program for someone who doesn't know
anything about it data science which is
focused on machine learning statistical
analysis coding and r and python
genomics which is focused on variant
analysis for cancer and infectious
diseases
metagenomics and bioinformatics for
infectious diseases primarily because
there's such an interest in covet 19.
and so what that means and i'll just
give you two examples here
in our introduction to bioinformatics
program which is by the way available
for free across nepi and lbrn
is a
brief introduction to the applications
of bioinformatics the need of
bioinformatics in different domains
the intersection between biological and
data concepts and an introduction to the
technical side of bioinformatics which
is coding in bio in r and python
in addition to that we have
specialization tracks that are really
papers
from that domain
explained in terms of their
bioinformatics methodology providing
with the technical and reproducible
tools for someone else to replicate that
study and that it covers oncology
infectious diseases neuroscience and
agriculture
now many of these examples are like i
said available through coding and
non-coding tracks
and that means that we have a variety of
tools that one can use to produce plots
that are standard and used
and learn along the way while building
pipelines
what those pipelines represent and how
do they transform data into something
that is biologically interpretable
in addition to that for those that
decide to go deeper and beyond that we
also offer a full process from context
to the logic of the analysis to then
practical tools that they can
kind of learn themselves using
different tools like google colab
to not only do the analysis but then
also save that code that they could
potentially replicate in the future and
so like i said one of the major
objectives is to elevate the level of
biomedical research by bringing a lot
more students into the bioinformatics
space and giving them the tools to get
started quickly because i think most of
the learning actually happen
when you do the learning when you do the
analysis and so as you struggle to come
up with the results and you have to find
out how to do a certain figure you know
that's really when you learn so that's
really the concept of that
and uh to support that the online portal
that we have designed
called omixlogic and i'm just going to
put the link here in the main chat if
anyone wants to take a look at that it
is
learn.omixlogic.com the sign up is free
um anyone can get started there are a
lot of free resources available
moreover it's very easy to go from the
very basic and free to the much more
advanced and kind of research oriented
type of type of types of activity
and those include not only activities
for learning but also activities to
understand
how students learn and that is another
important topic i think in the domain of
bioinformatics and data science
education is that the approach is to
give tools and and kind of show skills
but in reality the learning happens um
with a lot of variation across different
types of learning styles and learning
techniques and so we're always excited
to incorporate new ideas that come from
experts that are already a part of this
exciting network and so just as an
example of that we've been working with
lbrn to identify important resources
that are already being taught and used
throughout the network to incorporate
them into our learning portal and make
them available to students across the
network
one of these
is by dr jimanchi raje
from nicholls state university a
graduate of lsu who developed a course
that is important for students who are
joining any kind of biological
curricula
to incorporate the data component into
that as well and so he goes from the
very basics of understanding what does
biological data look like to a little
bit of coding and understanding how to
use packages in python so that one is
able to appreciate
the need and the application of
bioinformatics in life sciences in
general
so to support that process we're
actually making all of these resources
available
for those who are interested to
contribute coursework and and make that
coursework available throughout the
network and that means that we can
support development of training
materials
develop easy to use data analysis tools
help analyze their data set and and turn
publications into a tutorial
and also help develop interactive data
stories around those data sets and
important research topics so that
students can really benefit
from that
now i'll finish with my last slide where
i'm gonna just mention some upcoming
opportunities
so recently we started this discussion
about this upcoming summer
what is really important in the summer
research program how can students get
some training and
expertise in bioinformatics
for the previous two summers i think we
had a lot of interest
between 50 and 100 students each summer
we're participating in the research
training
on different topics and we often have a
lot of different topics at the same time
so i think on one hand that's a benefit
a lot of students can pursue what
they're already interested in in another
way that's a limitation because people
don't understand what goes into that
training and so what we're going to do
this summer is we're going to talk about
single cell and bulk rna seq
transcriptomics and cancer
we're going to talk about covid19 again
and continue uh offering training on
variants of concern as well as
microbiome and metagenomics in long
covet
we'll have a training program for
machine learning and data visualization
in bioinformatics using python and
plotly and building interactive
dashboards to make exploration of data
easier
and we hope to introduce a new
specialization which is going to be
focused on agrogenomics
and we'll use the example of cannabis
to talk about genomics and
transcriptomics for agriculture and
biotechnology
so with that again thank you all for
listening to my presentation i'm happy
to answer any questions that you might
have and if you're interested you can
also get in touch with me directly my
email is amelia pine.bio
thank you everyone
all right if anybody has any questions
for chris or elia
the floor is up
that was very informative by the way
chris is the
ceo of pine bio i
i missed in introducing him and
helio
that curves
yeah it's my apologies once again
alia is the ceo of
pine biotech and
[Music]
he mentioned the tauber institute and i
think
they've had
located at university of haifa
as the bioinformatics part of it was led
by his dad dr leonidroski
and
he's been a tremendous
asset for us and
many of our
researchers in the lbrn network have
have availed
the services
of pine biotech through the lbrn core
through the gene lab core and
i'd like
i'd like to believe that so far they've
been happy and i've heard gotten
feedback from a bunch of them saying
they are
very happy with the way interactions
have taken place
anybody has any questions for
dr christopher taylor or mr elia brotzky
okay
all right um gus wants
um well take uh now is the time for a
brief pause we are actually five seven
minutes into our pause so we'll
reconvene in
um
seven minutes time and for our next
session
and gus will introduce our next speaker
then